How is courtship different from dating so commonly?
Dating does not usually have marriage in mind,
but it's usually very recreational.
People will date for years without getting engaged,
or they'll date multiple people, etc.
Most of the time
casual dating leads to hookups as well.
It tends to be very emotionally based
and infatuation is usually
the factor that leads people to date.
Intentional dating is different from casual dating.
Intentional dating is what most Christians do.
Marriage is the end goal
and the couple spends the time getting to know
each other more seriously while dating each other,
but often date
for a short amount of time before getting married
and there will usually be agreed upon
physical boundaries.
Courtship is different from both of these.
Courtship is usually more family centered.
The couple is often set up by the parents
and often doesn't go on dates.
For me we spent most of our time together
hanging out at my parents house.
The couple does go on dates,
so usually chaperone.
The couple usually does not spend um
time alone together before engagement
for accountability purposes.
There's usually stricter physical boundaries.
For example,
my husband and I didn't touch until we were engaged.
There's also greater emphasis on
getting to know each other.
I'm on a deep level
then spending time going on dates.
Most of our courtship we spent emailing
each other back and forth about our beliefs on theology,
marriage, the family, etc.
Decisions are made Logically.
And there is very little emphasis on
the romantic side of things before engagement,
so do not skew decisions.
There's a summary in the caption,
but once again,
let me know your questions
and I'll do my best to answer soon.